hey everyone welcome back to kobani
Beach this might seem a little bit
strange because I'm hijacking this video
from the ladies Island as so just a
quick disclaimer at the start here
things have been kind of messy this week
because what was lady's turn her cat has
been sick the entire week and she's been
caring for the cat and doesn't have any
time to run the channel on the side and
because of that we kind of have a bit of
a time issue this week and we're
basically going with backup plan B which
is me putting together a quick video
just working on some general stuff so
that next week we can have the regularly
scheduled return with corrales and not
miss out on the week of koala beach and
that's what we're going for so I'll be
your host for this video
I am very sorry that I'm not the ladies
I know and I'm very bad at even trying
to impersonate versum not even a try but
I'm going to be doing some detailing
around my area because I don't want to
do anything that but like has a very
large impact on the park as a whole
because I don't want to start just
creating the entire Park and not leaving
anything up for them so instead I'll
just retreat to my little corner which I
had over here and work on some very
small detailing aspects that I needed to
get in and one of the very interesting
things is you've already seen the flat
ride I figured that would be a nice
addition to the corner there as it was
quite a bit of open space and it kind of
helps make me wooden coaster look a
little bit bigger since there is that
nice framing and a little bit of force
perspective even in the future with
having some small hills on the bottom of
that but also there was a little bit of
space left next to the station building
and here's something which I've been
wanting to do for quite a while and I've
seen quite a few comments about this in
the videos as well it's a locker room or
at least a place with lockers where you
can put your stuff in the Green Park
which are very commonly see especially
around major areas or major rides
and it's something that we don't have in
this point yet but something that I
definitely want to try and build and
it's it's a great way to fill in a piece
of an area since there wasn't really
anything else that I wanted to fill this
in with there is already a lot of
foodstuffs so I'm not too worried about
that so it's it's a nice fellow but it
also helps to make this entire area look
a little bit more realistic I feel this
would be the kind of ride we're in a
park this size kind of similar to
Universal and Disney I do have some some
kind of small Locker area even if it's
not too big actually you know this park
is still mostly inspired by Busch
Gardens but I guess this is the same
point still holds it's an addition which
i think is both nice in terms of realism
and just a nice looking addition into an
otherwise kind of dead corner of the
park because obviously I wanted to have
a bullet bar next to the lake but of
course you wanna have something at the
end of that Boulevard you don't want to
just have a dead-end doesn't go anywhere
it just looks good for no reason
so there's the ride and there's the
locker rooms over here as well and it
should hopefully be a pretty nice
overall area to stay and maybe I'll add
some kind of stall to it or at least
have some way to make the water phone
also a nice place to stay and sit down
on a bench and have some food or
something you know just a relaxing kind
of area also an area where you can
actually look at the roller coaster
because personally I think that's one of
the most important things I'm not a big
fan of roller coasters that sort of hide
away in the back and don't have any
paths next to them I think they can have
their charms but I just love it when a
roller coaster is very opening when some
of the greatest parts of the coaster are
directly next to a part and so even
people who don't want to ride it
can still have a cool look at it or even
the people who do want to ride it can
have an awesome look at it before they
ride it
I'm just a really big kind of past
interaction with coasters and you might
be able to tell so in that sense
dragging out the path over here and
least giving it some kind of credibility
to its existence just kind of feels like
a nice way to neatly tank together the
entire area here and this does mean that
I have to find some way to end the
bullet fire because this park is named
qawalli beach and we better have a beach
in this park otherwise this is
misleading marketing one on one so I
already have a very small Beach down as
the the area where trellis built most
service bora-bora huts and where the
entrance paths to the huts are as well
but I figured that's not really enough
and what I think would be really cool is
to actually add more of a beach
alongside the wooden coaster and kind of
had the wooden coaster slide through the
side of that and over some dunes etc
we'll see in the very near future what
that's going to look like just testing
some random ideas all the time over here
and honestly a lot of the work is also
general detailing since I wanted to go
quite in detail when it comes to all of
the small parts of the park and well
it's definitely some of the things that
I love about this game just the fact
that you can make your own lampposts and
make your own planters and everything
and copy them around and save them is so
fantastic but especially in a case like
this where I want to make everything
custom and I also have different
variations within each area it's very
time-consuming thankfully though we can
at least share blueprints around so we
can all use each other's blueprints
which has been going super awesome so
far and it's a great way to at least
make everything a little bit more
flexible and also a bit more cooperative
I suppose but it's sometimes it can be
very time consuming to put together all
the blueprints anyway here I'm making
the lockers and this was one of my
favorite points that just yeah some of
these lockers that you that you have to
buy the key for it
you know how it goes basically they're
the lockers you put your stuff in them
and that pretty much means that your
stuff is more or less safe it's not too
many actually they there are quite a bit
larger than I was hoping them to be like
somewhere around four or five lockers
and seems about the right height maybe
even a little bit more when you compare
it to the height of regular person but
since the blocks the digit in Eric
primitive building form blocks are a
little bit larger than the locusts that
I was looking for there aren't actually
too many lockers on this thing so we
better spread these things throughout
the park because this is not going to do
but anyway yeah this is just filling in
that wall and adding some small
detailing around to finish it off and
that's pretty much the simple building
here it's very simple building and very
similar to the buildings they've already
built so I'm trying to add some
variations to the theme literally and
figuratively
as much as I can with having the offset
roof on the back of the building and
having the roof sticking out on the
front here with the nice sign underneath
it reading lockers for anybody who has
poor eyesight I guess or doesn't know
the locker is there I guess I could
actually replace that sinus that's
pretty damn obvious oh well it's good to
have a sign anyway now for a little bit
more seeming I wanted to make the queue
line for this ride a little bit more
interesting as well and I think it
really needs too much because the queue
is already purposely wrapping around the
ride so that while you're standing in
the queue and being very nervous you can
see everybody go upside down and go
crazy for a couple runs before you can
actually enter yourself so that kind of
interaction is always interesting with a
queue and a ride because queues or I
mean I've set this before but I'll just
say it again there's some of the most
important parts of a park in a sense
that most people are going to stem spend
most of their time inside of a queue so
you better make it worth it and this can
be with scenery and making sure that the
area around the queue is as nice as
possible but having as much in sir
with the kosis of the rides that you're
standing in the queue line poor can
always be a great thing as well and even
the most generic queues can benefit just
from being very close to the right that
they are in queue for in this case
though I didn't really want to go too
overboard with making the queue and just
put a quick roof over it which I guess
is going to be nice in the rain but it's
more or less just adds a bit of theming
to the area and then after that I wanted
to make a couple of small hills
underneath the coaster and add in some
rock work for detailing and in a sense
it's a little bit forced perspective ish
so take that with a grain of salt
because it's more or less just about the
idea of what this area looks like as
you're approaching it because these very
small hills are kind of like sending
doing hills that make it seem as though
the coaster is standing on top of them
behind the flat ride which hopefully
should all visually stack up to give you
this idea of the flat ride being a
little bit low even if it's a very large
flat ride and then on top of the hills
behind that and towering high above the
flat ride having the very menacing
looking rollercoaster which just kind of
looks bigger than everything else
because everything around the
roller-coaster drop is just quite small
some I hope image is putting extra small
trees around the drop here and of course
the looker building is also quite small
see how the way that this entire area is
set up should hopefully make the Bullock
coaster look a bit more menacing because
it's it's not too ridiculous in terms of
heights it's very standard height
actually so that's definitely not where
it's getting most of its real strong I
guess I do like the way that it's
curving though I'm still not sure if I
should call it a gravity group coaster
or a GTI coaster since the first part of
the coaster is very GCI ish and so it's
the last part actually especially with
having the transfer track fly by but
then some cards are very hilly and very
straight in a sense that
it's more gravity group ish and besides
it doesn't have the trains of either of
them so it's just a wooden roller
coaster the reason that I'm talking
about these company so much is just
because I'm me and I like that kind of
aspect in quotes I'm just not sure what
I would categorize this as because
there's those vast amount of different
wooden roller coasters out there and
they all have very minor differences
that you might not notice when you know
as in to the companies but when you are
it can be a pretty stark annoyance when
it doesn't exactly line up to what the
typical causes of the company are so for
instance PCI which most of this coaster
is inspired by is a company which
usually features curve drops has barely
any straight sections whatsoever rarely
ever has very large Hills it's all very
close to the ground very quick twists
and turns everywhere and gravity group
especially some of the recent ones are
quite similar to that assuming but they
are they do features from large scales
as well and are sometimes more spread
out there's very subtle difference and
if that's very hard to describe really
and then there's some of the olden
wooden roller coasters that are just
open back with simple hills as hybrid
wooden roller coasters which are
completely different and there's there's
so much difference the father I'm not
going to go into the details too much
though because that would seem a bit too
nerdy but that's basically why I care
about this coaster so much because even
though is one of my favorite layouts
it's one that feels a bit like it in the
uncanny valley as to what manufacturer
would realistically make it if this were
a real park I'm kind of lagging behind
because of that tangent though because
I'm heading into the final part of the
time left and this is very very brief
part after just generally sketching out
the area around the wooden
a coaster and by that I really mean
generally sketching out it's just a
general idea of what it's going to look
like not the final detailing whatsoever
but also zooming that's I figured I
would give Corrales log flume a small
visit because there were some parts that
were still somewhat unfinished and I
figured I could just put in and put some
stuff here in there I hope he doesn't
mind trellis if you're watching this
please I have the best of intentions
Here I am I just had some find lies to
fill in this episode and I figured if
I'm not going to start anything new and
just let you guys do whatever with the
layout and make sure that it all fits in
the end I might as well just go back and
backtrack for a little bit and a bit
more detailing without really changing
anything through the areas that we have
so far so a lot of this is just adding a
bit more extra rope small shrubbery all
that good stuff it's always quite fun to
place these things even if it's it's
very kind of simple almost therapeutic
kind of thing to do
just put on some good music and play
some ground shrubbery and you can have
almost like I don't know meditation
session on video games maybe that's
pushing it a little bit I do love doing
this though I've actually been listening
a lot to it kind of tropical music
especially while doing this as well
I've listened a lot to London Calling by
The Clash just because it kind of fits
the reggae atmosphere the same goes for
the Senate mr. album so series shout out
the clash for allowing lots of koala
beach time lapses but yeah that aside
we're almost done with this episode I
want to thank you guys for staying
through my enormous tangents and my
stream of consciousness for now I'm
sorry about the rest not being available
right
and I'm generally sorry on my behalf as
well for how it's gone this week it's
just we can't do anything about it
and what happened with the ladies cat is
very unfortunate and very sudden and
very surprising as well so this is just
about the best that we can do for now I
hope you guys don't mind too much and
hopefully we'll be back with the regular
schedule next week so I'll see you guys
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]